what's up you bad [ __ ] huh with
Joey smoker the ball from last night
left over when I got back from the store
I'm as well finish it what you [ __ ]
savages or why wait when let reefer go
to waste there's some like it with flies
on an African going I could use a
[ __ ] number right now but beside that
was happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle Joey hits Friday March 18th you
survived st. Patty's Day who gives a
[ __ ] people dress them up in green
jumping up and down get DUIs I'm over
here smoking weed with [ __ ] foreheads
with the one-eyed Julie on Sam
hello it's Halloween l got Itoh my veto
is [ __ ] on today it's all over what
you got to do today you got you got the
world by the balls you even get the
paycheck or you're not understand you're
gonna sit there with some [ __ ] hook
or you're gonna sit there with a couple
Chinese try to go out tonight and get
your balls Lake my big insane
I love this [ __ ] I love smoking with you
[ __ ] in the morning and if you
would think of a smoking reefer today's
your lucky day
doesn't we got [ __ ] some TVs we got
RJ [ __ ] 26 - this is concussion og
every time you smoke this you got a
[ __ ] concussion I'm saying you're
like a [ __ ] quarterback so we're
going deep you understand I got time to
[ __ ] around with you [ __ ] it's
Friday I can't say yeah I feel like a
bunch a half a [ __ ] st. Paddy's was great
I got a purple shirt on today I don't
give a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] you
gotta go out there and be the best you
can be they swinging dick giving a
bubble gum and [ __ ] bazookas you
understand me because if not you might
stay in bed staying but are you wasting
your time and people's time going up
there half-cocked unless you've got a
bullets on the [ __ ] chamber or 14 in
the clip and one of the [ __ ] good you
ain't dick today get the stand man it's
that simple I'm not saying go out and
get a BB gun you don't need that or you
need this balls hard
and the ability of spitting upon the
[ __ ] as I thought understand me
enough with this little broach and death
let's get down there bigger thing we're
gonna open up at this farm crashing oh
geez
every ton of people spoke this they
gotta put a bandage on their head don't
ask me I'm as tough as nails just like
you this is the best part of my day
score this were you but enough with the
chitty-chat a Joey spark that [ __ ]
Indiana this is some good [ __ ] little
cousins
that's a [ __ ] cloud comes Luck's we
think it dealing with all these [ __ ]
dudes on Sunset Boulevard
I smoke some reefer it's a body I get
the [ __ ] out of here before kicking the
[ __ ] kidney a body are you [ __ ]
look
well gonna look at that my lungs don't
stand a chance
put those [ __ ] to the stress
test today I got breakfast I got
jiu-jitsu at 12 and I'm meeting at 1:00
2:30 and that's it for the [ __ ] day
it's family day today tomorrow I got
Bakersfield 9 o'clock and don't forget
[ __ ] 10 o'clock show San Jose
tonight and tomorrow night my main man
Redman George Perez and Kate Quigley up
there
don't let him [ __ ] down get your [ __ ]
together but Joe what do you a problem
spark that [ __ ]
enough is enough
let's mix it match with the fun say who
you kidding I can't let you go out there
today with just one [ __ ] boat
you gotta hit a couple [ __ ] pole you
know why you know why you're bad
[ __ ]
you may not know that but I'm [ __ ]
telling you did she is I didn't know
anything but I'm a [ __ ] Savage
especially the mornings I don't give a
[ __ ] can't eat meat today if you can't
lick I gotta have a little old bill
maybe a [ __ ] mashed potato cheese I'm
gonna some [ __ ] like that with wheat
toast you to come back with [ __ ] a
Philly roll for lunch
blondie come and save all the people
blondie come and say hello these people
over here hey blondie Rick do you see
[ __ ] blonde if she comes up here
blondie come in come in come see me on
asleep she lives with the [ __ ] Bush
this little beautiful kid I feed the
three meals that they're given nothing
but [ __ ] love and hopefully I'll find
their home she's a great [ __ ] cat man
I got a lot of [ __ ] stray cats in this
neighborhood but this one this is solid
I'd render up myself but you catch a
[ __ ] war yeah I'm too old and I'm a
baby but if are you looking for a little
[ __ ] cat in the California close to
Studio City hit me up on the [ __ ] is on
Twitter I got a solid caffee gangster
comes out me I come home at midnight I
just gotta yell up blondie she comes
[ __ ] running you understand me that's
a smart [ __ ] death she's a [ __ ]
survivor at you you want to have around
you let these [ __ ] once again that's
a [ __ ] survivor that kinda cat rubs
off on you
trust me
it's gonna give the front of my castle I
followed by you mate
that's a [ __ ] reefer and about our
date what will it do today not tomorrow
not one they tame you use the spear of
death for worship even who's better than
you today nobody gonna stop you hey
nobody gonna stop you if they wanna they
can't [ __ ] stop you remember I'm with
you you're with me and they're with us
everything else dream this rocket will
dream is sensational
it's real old-school [ __ ] sativa I
smoked this about 6:15 this morning I
could stop [ __ ] sing it Donna Summer
no time I thought I walked away hey what
I saw hello my book not the oh yes I
said what I said now it the heart is the
most [ __ ] important thing I know it
keeps the body detected what I'm talking
about harlot what I've so had thought of
this body I may not have anything but I
got [ __ ] heart that's why I'm still
here fifty [ __ ] three years okay you
know we went into some murky [ __ ]
waters
the Joey what is this this Bao Chau
smokey shut the [ __ ] up you're right hey
that's it I'm happy we got this little
time together get the weekend started
you know I'm saying right cuz your
family broke with our family you got
nothing you can have a million dollars
but without family you got oh God
okay remember that [ __ ] [ __ ]
nothing and I'm not my blood family I'm
talking about you [ __ ] with me
right now sit here doing this [ __ ]
number this is family but you can't
really do this with your [ __ ] fan
this is uncle Joey - Joey what did the
sir
what that's it
why we gotta lie to one another it's
Friday you're a bad [ __ ] and I
got you and I hope you got me
[ __ ] have a great weekend I'll
be checking in with you [ __ ] from
time to time if you want a spark keep
you out Twitter tonight we might do a
little something and that's it I love
you [ __ ] with all my heart grab
your ball salute the flag and you're a
[ __ ] American that's it that's it you
know what that means
you don't take [ __ ] from [ __ ] nobody
okay okay [ __ ] man look at the
Tony Shalhoub memory tell my celly gonna
beat that we will not be late and they
taught it to luck with a lot of boots I
get that mother-in-law finger I love you
[ __ ] stay black divine wellness
in the house we'll give a shout-out to
my main man Gino over I thought his
speed we'd making it happening even to
Joyce there they'll still scratching my
[ __ ] head anyway have a great day
keep the eyes open I [ __ ] love you
don't take [ __ ] from nobody till they do
your [ __ ] day